ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are here without
wi-fi in the middle of the desert in the
middle of a
california heat wave wildfires
118 degrees
scorched earth everywhere you look the
smell of
sulfur or burning
the brown landscape just being charred
in front of your own
eyes but that's where we've chosen to
make our stand
from that's where we've chosen to plant
our flag
here in the middle of the desert
literally on the surface of mars i'll be
here for a few more months and then i
have to rejoin
society little by little um
thank you to everybody who came out to
the stress factory in new jersey we had
a lot of fun
that is the club in america right now
that i believe
and this is from other people that have
done this as well that is
really uh having the best results
with an outdoor setup
the stress factory the owner of any
brand put a lot of money
into an outdoor fully functional
comedy club you have 150 seats
you have lighting you have sound you
have
everything that would make a regular
comedy club it really feels
like you're at a festival like an
outdoor festival
uh it's a great experience and we sold
out four shows there immediately
and for everyone that you know didn't
get in that wanted to get in we'll be
back
you know hopefully sooner rather than
later more shows
are being announced we're back out on
the road you know things are opening up
a lot of comedy clubs are opening up at
50 capacity
uh some are socially distanced and i
mean this is what we're gonna have to do
you know in the beginning i said i'm not
gonna be out on the road we didn't know
what the hell was going on
um i still don't want to perform in
front of cars i still don't want to
perform on the street
i don't want to perform in the middle of
a park i mean these are
i'm not saying i'll never perform at one
of those car things i'm a little curious
but i don't i i just don't want to do it
and because the show is
you know very successful and we could be
funny on this show
uh we don't need to do it thankfully but
um
now that things are opening up i gotta
go back out and be a comedian that's
part that's part of what i do it's part
of the attack
uh plan here you know and um
we're doing it as safely as we can i
mean the numbers are going down even in
the states that are hot
you know now the covid craziness has
become
q anon for the left this is what it is
it's
my aunt calls me about it she starts
quoting models and doctors from other
countries
and 80 000 30 000 to beds in the er
and you don't understand a latency pier
i mean
you know it's become a q anon movement
for the lefty the insanity and the
obsession with colvin i'm not saying to
not be careful
i'm not saying it isn't real i'm not
saying i can't get it and drop dead
tomorrow all of these things could
happen
what i am saying is that this incessant
need and desire
to sit at home drink wine and imagine
worst case scenarios is infecting the
body politic and it's not healthy
i'm just saying that on both sides on q
and on kids in the tunnels and on
everybody's going to get coveted
nobody's going to be able to draw a
single breath
that they are both unhealthy extremes
where people are imagining the worst
over and over again any boomer that is
plugged into politics
heavily is q or coven that is
it truly that is where they live they're
either hardcore q or hardcore covenant
you know they are
they might be your parents your aunt
your uncle they call you up and they
have statistics
when somebody has statistics ready it's
a problem
okay if you're out to dinner with
someone and they start
talking about a chart it's not going to
be a good night
if they bring out a model my aunt called
me i'm in the car i'm in a car i'm in
the cab
on the way back i'm with dan who opened
for me
um and we're on the way back to the
house and uh my aunt calls me starts
talking about models
so it's talking to me about the the
model they've built and the cover deaths
and what's gonna happen
and where we're all going and and i'm
like i'm kind of laughing and the cab
driver is laughing too
because it's like no one [ __ ] knows
anything about anything here
the one thing that we've proven over the
last [ __ ] six months is that nobody
really knows anything
some people have been more right than
others
but we're still figuring out what the
[ __ ] going on supposedly doctors now
have a better
way to treat this they have a cocktail
of drugs uh they're using ventilators as
a last resort
listen i'm not telling anybody what
risks you should take or what you
shouldn't take
but there's a whole hell of a lot of
people in this country that never got a
[ __ ] quarantine
they've been [ __ ] working have you
gone through a del taco they've been at
work
have you gone to a hospital they've been
at work when they're not tick-tocking
have you gone to a [ __ ] store or
grocery store they've been at work a lot
of people have been at work
so it's time to start dipping our toe
back
out there and going back to work there's
no other option there's no other option
you can't sit around
and and wait for a a vaccine that may
never come which i don't personally
really want
to put synthetic coronavirus in me
i've never gotten a flu vaccine i've
never had the flu
i don't want to walk into a walgreens
and get shot up with synthetic
coronavirus
some people do and that's great but i
personally at this moment in my life
maybe i'll regret that decision that's
what's great about decisions
you may regret them you may not but i
mean is anybody
excited about the coronavirus vaccine
i'm excited about the idea of there
being a vaccine
no one's excited for that needle nobody
i don't care who you are nobody's
excited
you like the idea of it you want other
people again give it to everyone else i
want to go to dinner
give it to everyone else but not one
person when you imagine the vaccine it's
kind of hilarious
you imagine it as like this [ __ ]
concept that you're never gonna really
have to get
right in line to get i imagine the
coronavirus vaccine is something i read
about the news
oh good good good the more seats are
open and whatever
i don't want to go to shop to lab corp
and get
a needle in my ass bill melinda gates
that's just
so we think about the vaccine it's like
an idea
that is a positive idea for society
overall but for me personally and a lot
of people that i know
and then i talk to nobody's running out
of their house demanding to be one of
the first [ __ ] trials of this thing
nobody wants yet you know we need it and
i hope some people get it but i don't
want to get that
let the other people get it you know
the others i'm not saying racially
give it to the elderly they're on a way
out let them see if it works see if it
works
i don't know people with pre-existing
conditions maybe they need it and want
it and it's
i'm just saying that we're back out on
the road
dates are coming tickets sell out fast
people are hungry they want to get out
they want to have fun you know we we we
we're not doing meet and greets we're
not be we're being careful
all these comedians that are [ __ ] on
people on the road are usually
comedians that have never been on the
road you know and they're like oh these
comedians are back on the road i'm like
you've never been on the road
what are you you no one's coming what
are you upset about
you know listen throughout this whole
process i never judged one [ __ ]
that went to work
i wasn't doing it like i'm not judging
you if if you put a needle in your ass
the minute that the vaccine debuts at
wherever the [ __ ] they're gonna start
letting people get it mcdonald's i don't
know
but i i don't judge any i'm going what
i'm gonna do
and what i'm gonna do is now kind of go
out because i've seen numbers and i've
seen things
that lead me to believe this is the
appropriate time to begin to
start going out but when there were
there were comics out three months ago i
didn't judge them and you do what you
got to do
you if you're earning money in live
situations
only or even just primarily you got to
do what you got to do i don't judge
anybody
you know i mean a lot of people have
been working
cops have been working
right i mean there's many videos of them
doing their jobs police
in major cities working
god man i saw that video where they put
a hood over a guy's head
and then they the guy suffocates and
then they push him into the ground
and it's like what what is the excuse
for that behavior
i mean truly the guy who was sick maybe
he had corona he had something they
didn't want to i don't know what the
argument's going to be yelling he had
kova 19 so they put a spit hood on him
to protect
themselves this was back in march yeah
it's part of the is part of the
medici medication for cover 19 slamming
a guy into the ground like
and then the guy suffocates man i mean
it it
the country's gonna burn i mean i don't
know what else to tell you like
you watch some of these videos and they
are
[ __ ] wild and they're you know you
don't know what's going on
and i talk about this in my act and i'm
not gonna give away this joke but
i would like to defend more police but a
lot of the people i know personally and
i've said it before on the show
that have car that are cops that have
guns should not have guns
so i do understand that there's we the
screening process for the cops is
apparently
i know people are gonna email me and go
it's actually great well it clearly
isn't
there's clearly a problem for smashing
people into the ground
you know we don't need to put hoods on
people i mean what i mean this is like
this is the way ellen degeneres treats
her staff
that's how bad it is putting hoods on
people it's not right
we were just in the uh the party store
we go to these dumb
halloween pop-ups a lot of times you
know one of the things about being in la
proper was that there was a lot of
costume shops there's a lot of places
you know the coronavirus costume the
epstein temple costume we had
actual costume designers design those
costumes because they have to be
really cool to look at but they also
have to be durable we get in and out of
cars we're all over the place
and um that was a benefit of being in la
but now we're in the desert you've got
to go to these halloween pop-up stores
and uh we're at this pop-up store just
looking at stuff you know might make
stuff
might not and i'm i'm looking at
this section of the store and i'm seeing
inflatable boom box
i'm seeing gold chains
i'm seeing hoop earrings and i'm going
this halloween's gonna go bad for some
people
i'm telling you that right now i don't
know what
section i was in but that was the
section of the halloween pop-up where
you're going to lose your job
that was dissection if you're white
i'm just say whether you agree with it
or not just don't
show up with hoop earrings and an
inflatable boom box
to the office party this year let's just
let this year be the year you do cat
ears
do sexy cat don't show up with gold
chains and dress up as run dmc this year
at the holiday party race relations are
not at the best moment
they've been just a little advice from
me to you
i know i know cultural appropriation is
kind of bs and
blah blah i'm just saying
for your own advice out there this is
really not the halloween to be
are they still making cop uniforms by
the way for halloween
i think we saw one yeah i think we did i
mean
good luck good luck going a sexy
derrick chauvin this year on
for halloween by the way i bet those cop
uniforms are gonna take a hit some
people will dress their kids up as cops
we support the police blue lives matter
you know there's some poor kid who's
like i want to be a vampire and you're
like
you're not going to be satan you're
going to be a cop
that's what you're going to be a lot of
parents are going to be dressing their
children up as police
um and then halloween is right before
the election isn't that fun right before
uh the election which from all of the
media reports should go off without a
hitch
should be very calm and peaceful
the media is literally going out every
minute going uh there's going to be
civil unrest
there's going to be uh i mean what are
we all preparing for
voting's already started it's mail-in
voting you can ready vote trump's
telling people to vote twice
everybody and i tweeted today
this is so much of a bigger problem than
trump trump is a big
problem he's not doing a good job that
being
i mean that's putting it as mildly as i
can put it for you psychopaths out there
they're like
no no so many people get mad at me when
i say that
no and here's the other thing he doesn't
like the military guys you know he
doesn't like the military
i think that article in the atlantic
should have been sourced but you know he
doesn't like the military
you know he doesn't respect people that
wear uniforms for no money i don't care
what you do garbage man
uh anything he doesn't respect that he
does not like the military
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about first
responders he doesn't get it in his own
mind he doesn't get he might not
actively hate them
he doesn't get it he doesn't get it why
a guy would wear a uniform and
potentially die
for a job that pays him 70 000 a year
maybe and that's not even i mean that's
like after you've been in for a while
he doesn't get that you're you you don't
get trump if you think
he's perplexed i think he's genuinely
confused
as to why anybody would do anything that
doesn't net them
a lot of money and the ability to [ __ ]
models
and live in a mansion or live in a
high-rise apartment like
he doesn't get it it's just not his game
you see
it's not what he's into he doesn't he
doesn't respect like uh
emt's first response i mean it's not his
thing
you think he really likes the military
by the way do you really believe
when you put your head on the pillow do
you truly believe
that donald trump understands like the
sacrifices
that servicemen and women make do you
believe that
you don't believe trump's a little
confused
you don't think if he looked and goes
you're making 36 000
a year what are you doing get out of
here
you don't think he's a little perplexed
by that
he doesn't get it what does he do that's
not for him
what has he ever done in his entire life
that doesn't directly benefit him
well the presidency i love that people
go well he's president he's actually
losing money
he's not and also people there's some
people that would argue being the leader
of the free world's a
benefit some people would say that
that's a benefit
so he's not actually it's not a selfless
pursuit you see controlling a nuclear
arsenal
the world's you know most powerful
military running
you know the economy you know to the
extent he
wants to or can that's not exactly uh
a step down from where he was so
he doesn't like the military i mean it's
just what it is there's a great part in
that atlantic article this is an article
if you don't know
came out in the atlantic magazine
jeffrey goldberg who's the editor of the
atlantic
uh some of their shit's fine that they
write and some of it i don't like i
think they should have been on the
record by the way
fox news though did confirm a few high
high-ranking trump administration
officials that were on board with this
uh the military does not want him in
they do not want him in so you can
continue to like and love and support
him
the military doesn't want to they want
people they want recruitment numbers up
and the recruitment numbers
don't aren't high if you're joining
military and you think you're going to
fight your friend in the street
so when trump says we're going to send
the military in everywhere you might
agree with it you might say we need law
and order
but it doesn't exactly help it doesn't
drive recruitment numbers
if you think you're going to be deployed
on on your streets fighting
nobody really signs up for that so the
military
is just a lot of them are just not a fan
of this guy some of them are some of
them certainly are
but a lot of them aren't and they know
he's doesn't respect what they do
they know that and you know that if you
think
doesn't respect can you imagine
explaining to trump
why you joined them like i believe
that i'm making a sacrifice for other
people's freedom
his eyes would glaze over in his head
like you were speaking in alien language
by the way my eyes almost glaze over
in my head when you tell me that's why
you're joining the military
i am a little like what
i'm like and by the way i'm glad people
do it but after we know
what the leaders of this country ask
these people to do
i'm a little like really like i would
understand much more if a guy goes i
love
killing i can't kill at home i gotta
kill abroad
and then i go okay he goes i like
violence that's how i come
i enjoy making someone go bye-bye
and i know that that's not everyone in
there there's a lot of people in there
that do believe in ideals and that's
great
but there's a few people in there's
certainly a few there's a couple of
people in there
that really just want to bathe
themselves in blood
and i would understand that as an
explanation almost a little more than
somebody who's like
i just want to secure our freedom and i
go okay
good for you again i don't understand it
either so stop pretending that trump
understands it
like i barely understand let's be very
honest you don't understand that
and if you did you'd be there unless you
are in the military and
and thank you for your service and
everything whatever
i do thank you for your service i mean
some of it some of it i thank you for
some of it i think we got to stop doing
i got to be honest
it's a half and half some of your
service i say yes and some of it i go we
can't do that anymore
it's a problem but i don't understand do
you understand it of all the jobs you
could get it's hard to understand
right it's very hard to understand i'm
gonna back up trump here a little bit
it's a little difficult to understand
i'm kind of with him if we were eating a
steak on the upper east side of
manhattan and donny turned to me goes
what the [ __ ] are they doing
i'd go yeah i don't know donny
yeah i don't really know it's freedom
and it's our freedom and they
he'd go thank god someone's doing it and
then we'd have a nice little cheesecake
i'm telling you
i'm telling you stop the fantasy that
this guy is like
some proud military historian who loves
the millage just
not what it is i know we need a military
they need to be strong they need to kick
ass
some some of my fans are in it i'm
[ __ ] happy they do it i wish they had
better civilian leadership
i wish the people in the military cared
more
and i don't mean the the rank and file i
mean the brass and more so than even the
brass the politicians
those are the problems i wish they cared
more about
veterans yes and i wish we had better
veteran health care
mental health care all of that [ __ ] 100
okay but let's just analyze for example
let's just take a look at
the decision that level of selflessness
of bravery uh you know in many cases
we're excluding now the sociopaths we
just want to watch things blow up
we're saying the other people that is
hard to understand
i don't i don't want to go to iraq
i don't
it's a little difficult to grasp and i
know that
and i know that we're all you know
everyone's horrified they're trump but
most guys that make millions and
millions of dollars
don't understand people that do anything
especially if it could kill them
for for not a lot of money they don't
get it
but people get people get high on
different things in life right
some people like danger some people like
risk some people like physical
physicality they want to be out moving
they want to work with their hands
some people want to sit behind a desk i
mean all those wall street [ __ ] their
risk is
is financial you know primarily like
they're not putting
their bodies in danger but they're
putting you know they might be putting
uh their family or their their financial
uh you know their entire enterprise
at risk all the time depending on the
decisions they make
and that could affect themselves their
company their employees but they don't
put their body in teacher
so it's hard to explain to guys like
that
why you would do a job that might get
you killed
it's tough you know when people become i
don't understand why anyone becomes a
cop
either i don't get it i get firemen
because it's fun
because there aren't a lot of fires and
they don't really do much
and they have these big meals in the
firehouse and the first
guy i sucked off was a i think a
volunteer fireman i don't even know but
something it was after 9 11 he was
trying to do it i don't know if he ended
up doing it or not
but he had a huge dick and i always
remember his dick like
of all firemen have that dick whereas
like not
insanely long but fat like a hose you
could use
now i don't know what happened to that
person i assume he's dead
but i'm kidding of course about they're
not being fires there are fires
in los angeles all the time there's so
many fires just kind of embarrassing
but everyone's like are you donating the
firefighters it's like not really
because the fires come back every year
so we're at a certain point now where
it's like i just don't know if we're
gonna get we're just throwing good money
after bad here
it's like guys can you do a job or not
i mean you do the job and then two weeks
later there's fires back so
i'm no expert and yet i still think
that's not really a good track record
okay people are getting evacuated
three or four or five times out of their
[ __ ] houses but i understand that job
but if somebody tells me i'm gonna be a
beat cop i'm just gonna walk around
and we need them we need people to do
these jobs but let
me but let's be a comedian that's a
great angle
who the [ __ ] on can go explain that to
someone
yes i'm gonna work for 10 years and be
broken maybe even longer than that
on the off chance that maybe i i
figure out how to be funny and then an
even slimmer chance
that i can market that to people and
make a living doing that and it's a
brutal
process so people don't understand that
no one understands anything really
other than like oh you make money got a
big house
so if i do the job that makes me i get
the house and the money in the car i get
that
but anything that you do that doesn't
immediately net you financial results
nobody in america understands i don't
understand it
and i do one of those things i spent a
decade doing it
i was just like a weird calling it was
something i had to do and maybe that is
the military but trump doesn't
understand that he doesn't understand a
calling
he doesn't understand like higher
purpose or the idea that this is what
you should do in your life
he doesn't get that everything's a game
this is he's a casino magnet
he's playing a game and why play such a
game that could
kill you why play a game that could
knock you out
and that's that's a fact and that's just
what it is
i understand you know but it would have
been nice if they sourced the article i
don't know maybe they will
folks a lot of us are starting uh
businesses online we know it it's the
way of the future you got to get on the
internet this is
it i mean you know we're we're this is
uh commerce here you know
you want to make a little bit of money
maybe you're an artist maybe you are
uh whatever you are and you're shipping
things right you want to ship your work
your wares maybe you are
somebody that's collected a lot of cool
stuff collectibles you want to get them
out of your hair people want to buy them
whatever you're doing whether you're an
artisan a creator whether you're some
type of broker
whatever you are if you need to ship
things and you have an online business
you should be using ship station ship
station is the easiest way for a small
medium-sized large or growing business
to manage their
outgoing shipping orders this is
essential you don't want to get bogged
down
with all the orders and all the things
you're sending out shipstation allows
you to easily
streamline everything you're doing you
want to focus on your craft
your business marketing building getting
your
uh you know name out there to more
people what you don't want to function
i mean what you don't want to focus on
is the functionality
of of your backend office and that's
where shipstation comes in they are
really enabling you very easily
to to basically ship things
to people all over the country and the
world right
they ship everywhere and it's so
important that you have
the confidence in the service provider
that you are using to do this it is
essential
the great things that chip station does
is they
allow you easily to scale up or down
their services depending on the volume
of business you're doing
at the moment also they easily
create a system which allows you to
track all of the orders that you send
very very easily none of this is
difficult even for people that are not
technologically gifted like myself and
many other creative geniuses out there
we can't be bothered
with the nuts and bolts hum drum
shipping crap
we need an infrastructure behind us that
allows us
to send stuff out there and to know that
it's arriving safely and securely
to the people who've chosen to buy it
worry about growing your customer base
do not worry about how those orders are
going to be
shipped that is the job of a ship
station and it's very very important
that you spend all of your effort and
energy
on what got you to start that business
in the first place whatever it happens
to be
could be your creativity your business
acumen whatever it is
let them do the nuts and bolts let them
do the back office work
and and you can easily track it so we
have a very special offer for people
that
are uh joining ship station
with the tim dillon show and benjamin
avery who's
back now will be telling everyone about
what that offer is
what is it so the tim dillon show
listeners can try
ship station free for 60 days what 60
days
free shipping for 60 days of a business
you've just started
that sounds too good to be true you just
have to use offer code tim dillon
that's it that's all i have to use is
offer code tim dillon and then i'm
taking all of my shipping
um expenses you know the same as a
fortune 500 company they use shipstation
and and and i get to use it for free for
two months yeah you just have to click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in tim dillon that's
shipstation.com then enter offer code
tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n shipstation.com make
ship happen
i mean if you're not doing that you're
crazy you get 60 days of trying this
amazing service for free after that
you're definitely going to be hooked and
it'll allow you to grow your business
safely securely
that's the move ridge
wallet yum ridge wallet is an
easily sanitized
easily concealed wallet and in these
times of chaos looting rioting
uh pandemics i mean the plagues biblical
plagues
don't you want a small sliver of carbon
fiber in your wallet
you don't want some big leather
grotesque thing that's falling apart
that little diseases can live in the
crevices of you want a
small wallet that allows you to easily
organize yourself put a debit card a
credit card
maybe a hundred dollar bill your
attorney's phone number uh next to kin
whatever it is uh the the ridge wallet
makes you streamline it makes you
organized it makes you realize what is
important and what isn't important
it's also an easy front front pocket
wallet
and it doesn't even look like a wallet
so nobody's gonna say let's rob that guy
important right now to have that kind of
thing it's also stylish
it comes in what again titanium
carbon fiber all these cool things so
cool
aluminum aluminum there's different
colors
i mean you're going to love it i'm
telling you right now god are you going
to love ship station you're going to say
i mean your god you're going to love
ridge wallet ridge wallet is so
great um everyone i know has a ridge
wallet and if they don't have a
originality i don't even
speak to them i don't want anything to
do with them because it means they're
not taking their life seriously and i
am i am taking it seriously i want to be
safe and secure
and so do you buy them for your children
your family be a ridge wallet
family easily sanitize you put it
between your hands
with a little sanitizer and boom you got
a safe
ridge wallet with no germs isn't that
nice it's important
and i believe ridgeway they've partnered
with our show for so long they're so
important they're offering a special
offer right now and it's very very
important
that we tell you what this offer is you
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going
to ridge.com 10 off
and free shipping and returns yeah and
returns if you don't like it and you're
gonna love it because it's got over
twenty thousand five star reviews
you're gonna love this wallet i mean it
changes everybody's life who gets it but
i'm
amazed ben that they're going to give
you 10 off and free shipping
yeah the link is in the description
rich.com [ __ ]
god would you lie about that it's so
easy it's right there i put it in the
box
in christ you wouldn't lie about that
would you
never because
if you don't do this i'm gonna come to
your house and kill you
ridge wallet yum
[Music]
get your ridge wallet
this article in the atlantic and you can
just put up because you have no wi-fi in
post you can just throw up
these two articles there's an article in
the atlantic
i'm sure there's an article about an
article in the atlantic and it was a
cover story in the atlantic that they
did on transgender kids
and i'm gonna try to get this right here
because i don't i
you know i it's so hard to talk about
without misgendering somebody and i i
i'm real we do not have the wi-fi
so i do i know that the person on the
article is now going by the he
him pronoun at the time they were going
by the they them pronoun
and i believe potentially before that
they were biologically born a female
because
we gotta say that right because that's
the whole thing about
transgender is that someone has a thing
with their biological sex they have an
issue with it and they wanna
so i'm trying to discuss this
respectfully okay i just don't have the
wi-fi
i don't have the wi-fi so i'm trying to
remember who everybody is at any given
moment it's a little difficult
it's a little trying
um the person shows up
they because at the time they were they
they sho because it's a journey
i think from from from female to they to
male perhaps
in this person's case right we're all
people
so
they show up to just do a photo shoot
for lgbtqia
x l e z k n i
i was gonna spell the n-word a little
bit and then pull back from it
because but i realize that that's just
not even funny but
i'm just gonna say [ __ ] just as a joke
and then pull back from it
just to see if any of you are paying
attention but none of you are
the point i was saying is that these
these
children show up to get the photos taken
the atlantic then makes them sign you
know that standard release we can use it
anywhere in the magazine wherever we
want
they put this person on the cover
of the atlantic and say your kid is
trans
the the kid had no idea they were going
on the cover their parents didn't know
the kids i think uncle or grandfather i
don't have wi-fi
had a subscription to the atlantic and
ended up being like oh man
this is blank i don't know the name
this is that person that we know um
and so the the kid and they also
misgendered the person they
mischaracterized the whole thing
it's really crazy and i and i read the
article
and uh and again it's it was a real
it was an article about
what to do or the debate around
uh children who want to transition okay
which i'm not saying anything about
right now i can't i can't wait into this
i don't have children you know there's a
certain point where
you got to step back you can't be in
every fight all the time
i've said before and i stick with it i
don't think anyone should do anything at
nine
people should wait till they're older i
don't know if that's age is 18 or if
it's in their teen
i don't know what it is i'm just saying
i don't think anyone should be making
life-changing decisions at
six but i don't have k i'm not i'm
really not if i can't get involved in
all the fights i can't
i can't be involved in everything
everything can't be
god bless these people that every day
brett weinstein and heather heing and
all these [ __ ] every day they
every day heather hines like hello
it's heather hying hello it's heather
and then brett's like hello heather
today
as portland is bombed we're going to sit
here with our cat
and discuss you know and it's like i
understand
i get it and i'm sure everyone's serving
a function i just can't be involved
i have to i have to step back i mean
i have to draw a circle around myself
and only care about certain things
i you know it is what it is here if i
have a child
if i have a child i will encourage that
child to be a financial criminal
regardless of gender i will encourage
that child to go into banking
to live in the hamptons to have a you
know to live in the city to have a home
in the hamptons
i will want that child to work in
private equity or hedge funds
i will i i i i and like that like the
transgender person on billions the
non-binary
person on billions i would hope that
that is my child i would hope
that my child in addition to being
non-binary would be
um kind of a numbers whiz with a real
real kind of loose sense of morality
that could infiltrate
an institution and that that would be my
hope i mean that would be my hope i
don't think i'll adopt a child but
if i do adopt a child when i sit down
with the adoption agency i'll say is
there any way that we can know which one
um you know will be a criminal because i
would want that one like an intelligent
criminal not an idiot and a bodega
[Music]
but like a fun criminal because that i
would want to give that kid advice
and i think you know when i'm older in
my life if i have a child if i have the
the you know if i adopt if i'm in a
relationship with somebody
who's sober which is a big and
they're uh you know not in jail or
something and we want to have a child
or like raise a kid which i don't think
sometimes i think about like i don't
know like i think about getting a dog
i have a dog for an hour and then you go
this is enough so
uh but it might be nice to raise a kid
but i'd want the kid to do something
i'd want a [ __ ] real deal like
olympic
kid like i wouldn't want a humdrum
regular loser i'd really want
like a kid who was like obsessed with
sports or
you know a chess grand master you know
not like bobby fischer who just wanted
to he just starts talking about the jews
but i mean someone just displays a
tremendous amount of skill at something
i want a driven kid you know i want a
kid that it's hard to relate to
i open the door to his or her room or
their room
and uh they just kind of look at me with
disgust because they have no respect for
me because they're like yeah you have a
big house but you're a fat clown you
know
what are you really what are you what's
your legacy i want my kid to say to me
what's my legacy and i want to crumble a
guy i don't think i
i don't i could just say you know comedy
doesn't really age i don't know you know
but i want my kid to be like a stone
cold
little psychopath that's what i want i
don't know if i can get that
i don't know if i'll get that but that
that's kind of what i want like a tough
sharp you know i mean that's that's what
i would like
if i if i had the chance to to have a
child
you know that's all
you know it's also like what kind of
grandparents would my child have because
my mother is
insane and my father is has a putting
green in his backyard
so it's like what exactly am i bringing
the child into the world
in terms of grandparents for like what
guidance will my
child will clearly get no guidance from
my parents you know who gave me no
guidance
and uh gave themselves very little
so my parents like many boomers are just
on a sailboat
sailing the wind is blowing them around
and they'll land where they land
um so the idea of you know like where's
grandma and grandpa you know where's
grandma well grandma's in a mental
institution
and grandpa's uh putting in his backyard
you know but the election's gonna be fun
folks get ready for the election it's
it's gonna be a fun one
and i i do think
democracy has not worked can we say that
can we put that out there as a thesis
can we throw that out as a thesis and
then work backwards from there
yes or yes i'm i'm asking you do you
look around and feel that democracy
has really worked maybe it hasn't even
been tried i mean we're a republic we're
not a democracy
but uh we're not even that we're more
like an oligarchy and then that's also
failing right the oligarchy's kind of
failing because
you know dave smith made a good point
about this
i'm not a libertarian but i do like dave
a lot um
people we we all know the people are
nuts
you know the people a lot of the blm
antifa types that are like knocking over
restaurants
are nuts we know that we see them we go
that's a crazy person
we see we we say that's a crazy person
because we know
there's no root from what they're doing
to anything
better right we know that by knocking
over brunch tables we're not gonna we're
not getting to an equitable fair
uh society where people are treated with
respect and it's also the wrong goal
by the way the goal should be
uh to change laws and to have laws
uh govern people's lives so that they
have uh the maximum amount of
opportunity the goal should not be
um to uh create or
change everything at once because none
of that ever happens or ever works
um each we should there should be
specific pinpoint
focus on things that are [ __ ] people
and that you can change and and that it
you it shouldn't just be this broad
eat the rich horseshit that never works
never has worked
um and and the other side of eat the
rich is just some type of authoritarian
uh socialist uh state that is run by
people
that will uh corrupt like every leader
does and then run the state into the
ground
and run everybody uh that lives there
into the ground as well
um that's just historically what has
happened right there's no
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
like the carried interest loophole on
wall street you should eliminate
that should be a [ __ ] get rid of that
first
does it mean you don't do anything else
but it means like there's things you can
actually [ __ ] do
or try to do um but we know that the
people knocking over
the brunch tables are nuts and we know
on the other side the people that are
walking around
talking about an ethno state uh you know
with ar-15s you don't really want to
throw your hat in with those people
either that's just not what you
you look at both groups of people you go
i bet they're not going to run a real
great society
if we give them the opportunity right
17 year old gamers who want to bring
back the monarchy
versus fat non-binary women from seattle
both
options negan for society
but we forget and this is dave smith's
point how radical the center is
how crazy the center is
how truly detached the elites are the
center
they have also left the planet
the center and i don't mean the
the majority of people in america when i
say the center i mean the people that
have any power
any influence the people that are
elected the people that are behind the
people that are elected
those people as well are completely out
of it the
centrists the ones in the middle cannot
just be
for eternal war and a financial system
that crushes people
and and and no health care and that's
the center
those are the safe people that's the
safe
choice just unending war
manipulating [ __ ] you know
currency crashing economies all over the
world
driving our economy off a cliff every
seven years
in his boom and bus cycle you know
charging off all of our debt letting it
be serviced by all these other countries
that's the center and that's
also a big problem i think people forget
that because it's easy to point out
how crazy the people on the streets are
but why are the people on the streets
because the center
the people in the suits the people that
look respectable
the people that have lovely families and
you go sit down with them you have lunch
with them
when they start talking you go oh you as
well are [ __ ] insane
you as well have lost it i was in the
hamptons talking to people they're going
isn't the aren't the problems mainly on
twitter
i'm like they're burning down what
did cities are falling and you people
are drinking rose in your backyard
they don't have a clue they're out of it
they're living in this
insular bubble they have no idea
what is happening and they're the center
they are the buddha judge
klobuchar centrist they're not
people that you would ever uh point out
and go that's a lunatic
but when you hear them talk and when you
realize that the policies they
they don't think it's a problem that we
have the
level of wealth and equality that we do
they don't think it's an issue
um and i and i and one of them said to
me that one of them said well wait a
minute
they go what is this so what's the
problem with this so wealth inequality
so i'll give you a few problems but i
said the the one the one major
one of the major issues that i can
because i'm i'm i'm smart enough to
realize i'm not gonna try like an
emotional appeal with these people
i said a lot of if you have a small
group of people
that have all of the money they also
have all the political power
so the problem is that in a democratic
system or a republic or whatever we
[ __ ] are under the impression this
thing is
if you give all of them if the money is
earned and
hoarded and capped by one small group of
people they also make all of the
decisions
uh syringe in your ass bill gates you
know so that becomes an issue too
and um and they said oh i can see your
point there a little
i go yeah a little bit i see that i said
you see
she said people don't have any power
anymore right
yeah yeah yeah and then one of them goes
well they can vote that's what they say
you can vote just vote
what's the problem and i'm like yeah but
the lobbying and the legalized bribery
the bribery that isn't legal the
blackmail
all the skullduggery all the fun that
you people have been having forever
yeah that that kind of that that kind of
overrides the vote
doesn't it not saying you shouldn't vote
um and i'm not saying by the way that
the opposite of voting is like let's go
[ __ ] up a brunch
because somehow then these people are
going to be dethroned
but the centers is fairly radical it's
wild when you talk to people
and they're not radical in their
appearance and they're not radical
in um in in many of their beliefs like
many of them are
are pretty you know regular
you know down the down the middle kind
of but when you start talking to them
we're all radicalized by our
self-interest this is really what it
comes down to i think that's
part of the issue the radical nature of
a lot of people's beliefs
um sometimes it goes against their
self-interest
but a lot of times it is perfectly in
line with what they
want either the world to look like and
even if you don't understand someone's
self-interest like you look at all these
rich kids
uh saying that they want communism well
that doesn't make any sense
it does when you realize that they
actually just want
anyone to pay attention to them and that
that's the one thing they haven't been
able to buy
is their value and worth as a human
being
so that's why they're they're walking
around unironically calling themselves
maoists
walking at a starbucks with a cold brew
and then
and then stomping around the suburbs
saying that they're maoist they just
want [ __ ] attention
so that is in their self-interest but i
mean all these wall street [ __ ]
out there in the hamptons and i only
spoke to a handful of them
but the ones that i spoke to are are
incredibly detached from what is
actually happening out there they just
don't care
and and when they talk about it
their belief it is a radical belief to
say
is aren't the problems just on twitter
that's a pretty radical wild
take because they they can afford
the news many of them
are friends of the people who run those
company you know the news
right you could just turn it on or
glance at it occasionally
and you would see how big these problems
are and how widespread they are
to say something like isn't it mainly on
twitter
shows that you're just so completely
removed from it and that's why
a lot of these elites are just incapable
of charting the right course
for america so so if trump leaves don't
think for a minute that
the people coming in i mean biden was
chosen because he is a corpse make no
mistake
he was chosen because he is a corpse and
because he's a company man
and he's gonna go in there and they're
gonna keep
with the same policies and the same
attitude
that created trump that type of
empire at all costs [ __ ] the people
mentality uh politics is beyonce
shaking her ass and having a trans
batman that
level of commitment to the american
people
workers can [ __ ] off people that have
families can [ __ ] off
uh you know but if you want to jet
around to little st
james you'll have the best legal defense
possible
um but politics being primarily the
color of the superhero
is has not worked and that's what it is
a very aesthetic
optics-based politics in which nothing
gets done
by design and little people get little
uh bread crumbs a little nugget of this
and that here you go
enjoy this obama came in tried
you know that didn't work doesn't mean
that
uh you know so that's just that's how
radical
and and as far as the antifa people can
you start knocking over hollywood
restaurants stop with these like middle
class or upper middle class brunch
places in dc
start knocking over restaurants at
beverly hills because here's the deal
they're gonna
that the celebrities are kind of gonna
have to agree with you
like that's what's gonna be funny about
it they're gonna have to agree with you
they're gonna have to
like sofia vergara is gonna have to
throw a fork
and say black lives matter they're gonna
have to do it
like reese witherspoon's gonna have to
kind of go along with the chant
like she might be sitting there
completely like
wow but she is gonna have to be a little
bit like as they come in and start you
know
doing the table she's gonna have to sit
there and kind of go like
black lives matter i agree like that
because these celebrities kind of have
to do it right aaron paul
that guy from breaking bad let me go to
a restaurant he's
at you know
they're gonna go to go go go to where
bette midler's
hanging out they're gonna have to agree
right
they can't be like this is absurd
no they're gonna have to say yes yes
destroy it
yes beat me with a salt and pepper
shaker
why not i believe i agree with this
i agree with you i'm a great look at me
agreeing
yes dude the dude in the restaurant
beverly hills these [ __ ] idiots will
sit there and be like
yes good we agree
and of course the poor restaurant owner
will watch this restaurant get trashed
while these celebrities sit there and
cheer it on
cheer it on let let that happen why not
better help help folks i'm telling you
better help help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
many times i have those problems i get
up and i'm
sad or too happy sometimes too happy is
a problem people don't realize that but
when you're too happy it's very
off-putting people don't like that i
certainly don't
so how do you get even keel you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
with better help
it will help assess your needs and match
you with a licensed
professional therapist there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
or
which may or may not be locally
available in many areas you might not
get it in many areas you're living in
but you can get it with better help
because it's online especially now with
covid
a pandemic you want to be online
i'm telling you right now you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
like traditional therapy better help
help
is committed is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free
to change counselors if you need it is
more affordable than traditional online
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today
so easy if you've got problems you want
to talk them out these are real
counselors
real therapists they got licenses you
don't have to drive there
get parking it's expensive covered
you have to sit in an office while some
of the therapists you don't know is
chewing on a bat
this is a healthy way to live your life
go to their website www.betterhelp.com
tim d
that's betterhelp.com
timd and join over the 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offers for the tim dillon show
listeners they get 10 percent off your
first month
at betterhelp.comd 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
timdy it's such a good idea so many
people are walking around right now and
they're absolutely [ __ ] insane
and it's just better for them to get
help
some people tell me you know they say to
me sometimes i'm getting help and you
know what i say to them
i look them in in their face and i
say you're getting help they go yeah i
said
why don't you get better
help
how about that you know what they say to
me they say
what should i do and i go you go to
betterhelp.comtmd betterh-e-l-p-com
tim d do it guys do it
to support not only your mental health
but more importantly my show
do it it's so important for everybody to
have a nice
nice stuff going on in their head nice
stuff going on up there in their head
it makes it better and it makes it
help better
help the football season is less than 10
days away with the reigning champs set
to take the field to kick off
the season there is no better place to
get in on all the action than with
draftkings the leader in one day fantasy
sports
to celebrate week one of the football
season's draft king is putting you in
the center of the action with two shots
at a one million dollar top prize so get
it on all the action now
make it rain with draftkings is easy
draft your team
stay under the salary cap and pile up
points for yards touchdown and so much
more on top of that amazing offer
draftkings is giving away
of a share of up to 100 million dollars
in prizes
do you see uh 100 million dollars wow in
prizes to all the users who enter their
free
free football survivor pool all you have
to do is sign up for draftkings
enter their survivor pool and you'll be
instantly get a share of 100 of up to
100 million dollars in their giveaways
with all this cash up for grabs there is
no better place to get in
on the action with draftkings it's so
important so many people are having so
much fun
it's very very important and i think
it's important that you get in with
draftkings
because you can have fun you can build
your team there's so many prizes to win
there's so much cash to win
you're gonna do this stuff anyway why
not get involved and win a little cash
a little do you like cash yes do you
like prizes
love it the [ __ ] you do so get on the
draftkings download the top rated
draftkings app now
and use promo code dylan d-i-l-l-o-n
to get a free shot at a million-dollar
top prize and for limited time
get a share of 100 million dollars
that's [ __ ] oprah money
100 million dollars in prizes once you
start once you enter draftkings free
survivor pool
that's promo code dylan to get in on all
the action dylan
for limited time only at draftkings
minimum five dollar deposit required
other terms and conditions and
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details
draftkings.com it's party time
are you gonna party with a hundred
million dollars worth of prizes
or are you not because i know where i'm
gonna be
building the team entering the survivor
pool and get
my [ __ ] cash get my cash and if i've
understood this ad
if you enter you get 100 million dollars
that's what the ad says
if you enter this someone shows up your
house with 100 million dollars and i
think that's
nice protocol
dylan d-i-l-l-o-n
draftkings.com football
ma me yeah
we went to a restaurant the other night
we were inside we're in north salem
um there's a nice area letterman lives
up there nice here in new york and i was
there with a few people and the food was
so bad
but it was just so fun to complain about
you know to each other we didn't tell
the restaurant a few of the women at the
table like we should
you know we should [ __ ] lay and
because you know that area is just all
wasps and wasps don't complain about
food jews do
so that's why you know where jews live
you get good food because they'll
complain and ethnics will complain
um and people like my mother like she's
who's irish cat but wasps are but you
know above everything in their own head
so they don't complain they don't like
they don't complain because a wasp
doesn't want to even have eye contact
with the server
they don't even want to discuss anything
with the help so
if the dover soul wasn't good it's like
whatever it doesn't matter wasp
just want to be around other wasps so as
long as the restaurant looks like an old
inn
that george washington would go to and
as long as it looks like that and as
long as that uh
the uh makeup of the restaurant is
pretty
uniform if you know what i mean the
wasps don't really care they just
you know they go in with their bow shoes
they sit very quietly
they have very quiet respectful
conversations and then
you know the dudes go home and watch
porn that would make your eyes bleed i
mean the things that those people
probably watch
but that's what they do and i'm in there
with ethnics we got italians greeks
we got jews we got it was ethnics in
there and people you know we're loud and
we're fat
some of us not all of us but some of us
and when you know we're like you know
what a couple of them were like i wanna
yeah we shouldn't be paying for this
i was like i agree but we didn't we
didn't complain obviously we're not
we're not trying to hurt anybody
um but it was just so fun to sit around
inside the restaurant we said we
wouldn't think we'd be doing this to
just sit here it's a real luxury
to sit there and complain about food
that isn't good there's sometimes it's
really fun
to go to a restaurant where everything
is bad you know my uncles
works for a restaurant group manhattan
and they are some of the best
steakhouses in the country quality meats
and
quality italian smithinskis they're just
legendary spots
they're really good maloney and porcelli
and park avenue i mean
they're part of the fabric of what makes
new york dining great i mean the guy
that he works for
uh started tgi fridays i mean these are
legendary people
but they opened a restaurant called
quality french which was and i took two
of my friends there to history hyenas
chris and giannis and
i to say that the experience was
atrocious
i mean his restaurant they love doing
fun things like in one of their
restaurants quality italian
they have a chicken parm shaped like a
pizza
so they like doing fun tableside [ __ ]
you know they finish the penny alla
vodka with the lobster they finish it
with a flame next to the table and
they're you know it's it's a show
it's theatrics so the first thing they
do
they come over here is they go they have
herbed butter they bring out
a hunk and i mean a honk like this big
like the size of like like a small box
of butter just seeing
that amount of butter was so viscerally
disturbing
that we were like our stomach started to
churn
then the food started to come out and i
mean it was but everything was bad the
french onion
i went to the manager afterwards i said
listen i come to these restaurants a lot
i love them
this experience was atrocious and i am
now very upset
and i said i don't know and she was like
a sweet older asian woman she's like i
understand i'm like i don't
i don't know when i will be able to make
this okay in my own head what just
happened here
because what happened here was an act of
war
the the moo the chocolate moose
you know the chocolate moose has done in
a way that it makes it look like ice
cream
they decided to not do that they decided
to smear it
on a slate to make it look modern and
you know what it looked like
dog [ __ ] actual
[ __ ] it looked like i had stepped it
looked like a slate of concrete sidewalk
with a smear of dog [ __ ]
on it and i called the manager over and
said let me ask you a question
what does this look like she said what
i said what does it look like if i had
to ask you
to describe this in a few words
what would you say it looked like and
she looked down
and she said it kind of looks like poop
i said yes it looks like poop
correct why is it on my table why did we
pay
18 for [ __ ]
it was an atrocious experience but we
had so much fun
[ __ ] on the experience we had so
much fun
seeing something go wrong there's
there's
nothing better when i used to eat out in
new york i'd eat alone at the bar a lot
and you'd watch these restaurants
struggle to keep up with the flow of a
friday night or something and you just
see the wheels come off and the waiters
start to go nuts and shake and
you hear glasses dropping and people
like getting upset and the kitchen door
would open you just
brief screaming before closed again and
you know people were getting reamed out
and they were in the weeds you know it
was tough and
i would just watch that and it was
really nothing that made me happier than
just watching that operation just at the
at the brink just buckling under the
pressure of the flow of people
nasty loud taurus demanding new yorkers
just a cocktail of
horror and they didn't keep coming they
kept coming and i just sat
at the barn would just chew a soft
ciabatta just
and watch watch people lose their
minds watch them curse the decision they
made to move to new york
to be an actor or this or that watch
them
curse their co-workers watch their
hearts
filled with hatred while this was
happening i watched
customers roll their eyes hold glasses
up in the air for more
water pound on the table wanting to get
the attention of the server
crowd the maitre d similar to the way
the blm folks are doing now
almost in a threatening posture but this
wasn't about equality it was about
calamari
but i've watched all of that happen and
there's nothing more enjoyable than that
and i don't know why
it's a funny thing but i don't know why
there's nothing better i've been at work
i've been
when i was a tour guide i remember when
it was raining and people were screaming
they had tickets they were trying to get
on the double decker bus
that was a tour guide of and they
couldn't get on and i had to hang over
the bus and go i'm sorry another bus is
coming
and the people you know would just shout
and all their different accents they'd
go
saying liar cause they knew i was lying
lawyer you're a
[ __ ] liar and i'd have to wave to
them and the rain was coming down and
people we had to hand out ponchos or
trying to handle ponchos on the bus and
people are screaming and
the bus just old metal death trap they
pay off the city to just say it [ __ ]
works
it's weaving side to side and people are
screaming because they
they can't make their broadway show
tickets and they realize that the entire
vacation
has just been a succession of of
stressful
moments where they're just trying to
move from one thing to the other so i
understand
what it's like to be in that position to
be in that
nightmarish position and there's just
nothing better
than watching it just kind of eating a
soft ciabatta
there's just something about not being
at work it's not being there you know
was there ever something that went
really out of control
yeah when we'd serve liquor there on uh
wait hold on
i'm gonna flip out the name of the store
because i can't i can't
serve liquor i gotta bleep that out
again yeah
why because it's illegal it's illegal to
do we would do it on
like fourth of july days like that and
usually homeless
are you envisioning and i'm not gonna
say the name again but are you
envisioning people
suing or trying to get you in trouble
legally
uh maybe i mean okay it's highly illegal
to do well then well then you bleep the
two names and i won't say it again
can i say the genre of story sure it was
a pet store
you were serving alcohol at a pet store
why
to celebrate independence day and we
would do it on halloween
why are people celebrating uh
independence day at a pet store
because they want to dress up their pet
in the costumes that we have and
you had pet costumes as well yeah
[ __ ] wow
i thought it was just mainly like toys
chew toys and dog food
it was the whole works i mean it was
people that really loved their pets came
to that store
was there ever a question about a pet's
gender identity i'm dead serious
no but people would correct me if i said
he or she on accident
okay yeah i don't i recall one person
by the way there is it it it
it's a beast it's a beast
i'm reading a book right now about
people so what would go to when you got
people drunk
was there every situation we go this is
getting out of control
yeah this guy who loved birds came in
and he was he would talk to us for hours
and he got
just [ __ ] wasted in the store and we
basically had to ask him to leave
because he was just too drunk but people
would just get hammered and just kind of
hang out
a couple homeless people came in and
started drinking we had to ask them to
leave
too because you can't assume in like
eagle rock and silver lake that
someone's homeless
until you kind of put two and two
together don't give people hints about
the store now
giving people hints
but there's something nice about being
a person who's experienced hell while
you work
which that doesn't sound like hell it
just sounds a little annoying i'm
talking about real like
heavy workload people are going crazy
right
and um i've experienced that so to
to not experience that but to be
somewhere where i can observe
other people going through that that's
nice
that's kind of what all the people in
the hamptons are doing they're just
chewing us off ciabatta at the bar
staring at all of the waiters trying to
make it through the night they're all
just sitting at the bar
chewing just watching staring at it
looking at it in an academic sense
not really invested in the outcome they
don't really care if somebody drops a
bowl of lobster bisque on the floor
they don't really care if this girl is
going to sprain her ankle and not be
able to work
doesn't really matter to them they're
just chewing a little roll
watching it all go to hell
that's what they're doing you know and
people have to remember that that's
the problem all of the other things uh
trump people dressed in black a lot of
these people are uh
side effects of the medication
but the real issue is the people who
drove the country
to this point those people
who still don't care i mean they still
don't care
i mean there's riots in this i still
don't care i mean things are burning
that air still unconcerned
they still don't give a [ __ ] what would
make them care the white house will be
on fire they'll go isn't that on twitter
is that mainly on twitter that's an
instagram problem right
what do they storm the white house is
that a tick tock thing or is that
no it's real life crazy
[Music]
you forget how [ __ ] nuts these people
are just because they look nice to have
collared shirts
they're [ __ ] nuts i'm reading a book
about
people disappearing in national parks
called what is it called
oh a cold the cold vanish
the cold vanish yeah i just picked it
out at random in an airport because i do
that a lot with books i usually read a
chapter of it and then
say i'm gonna read the rest and never do
but this book is interest people and i
don't really
and the reason i don't care this much
about this topic is number one i don't
think it's bigfoot i don't think it's
aliens i do think people might be
getting abducted i don't care that much
about
nature of people that really seek out
nature i think they're very sick
i think people i don't mind you know
obviously a beach or something like that
but i like civilization i like
small town a couple of restaurants and
in a natural setting it's nice but i
think people that go into national parks
are very sick and very ill
and i believe that i believe if you're
looking for you know people that set up
tents and do like 10-day
camping in a national bar are very sick
people that have a lot to hide
truly i believe that and i believe that
if you are
in in those situations i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're into
so i don't know why you disappeared i
don't know what you're doing but you
you i think you're very very sick
and i don't know what's going on i think
a light hike is fine
but when you start telling me you're
like spending days upon days in
zion national but i mean get away from
me
oh you got to go to yellowstone get away
from me i'll go to yellowstone for a
minute
hey look at that
that's where satan is
okay so anybody that wants to be in the
woods for an extended period of time
i believe is out of their [ __ ] mind
i don't know what influence they're
under
spiritual or otherwise but i think it's
a big problem i truly believe that and i
know i say a lot of things
for effect here but i mean
you know all these peop joshua tree
everybody i want you gotta go to joshua
tree
and take mushrooms and then figure your
life out
i'll figure your life out for you first
instead of going to joshua tree blow
your brains out in the car
how about that i'll figure it out
don't bother the aliens with your life
decisions
i'll tell you what to do pull off the 10
east and swallow a desert eagle
stop looking for mystical experiences
and go to work
jesus christ we are a selfish generation
of sick [ __ ]
what do you want to commune with so what
you could get a better deal on sneakers
give up this mystical realm you all keep
[ __ ] around in
you are slovenly selfish pigs
you have no [ __ ] thought in
to what it would what are you gonna
commune with the uh
for what what do you think your terence
mckenna
you're going out to joshua tree to get
more energy so you could go back to your
job
ripping people off
take shrooms for the fun of it but don't
pretend it's a [ __ ] journey you're
not a shaman
you're not a shaman you work at a
production company to make shows about
midgets
i'm just saying
enough already with the nate the
national parks who gives a [ __ ]
can we solve the blood in the streets
the streets are running with blood
stop with the park all the time and the
hiking in the [ __ ] view
i mean christ almighty enough
stop fleeing to these [ __ ] parks
so you can sit there and get high by
rock formations the earth is burning
civilizations buildings bridges
restaurants schools hospitals let's
figure that out
enough already we want to take like a
trip
and i hope you get abducted i hope a
bear
rapes and kills you stay the
[ __ ] out of nature
it's disgusting nothing makes me happier
than when instagram people take a photo
on like a cliff and then die
immediately afterwards nothing fills my
heart with hope
more than that and i hope that keeps
happening
a little beach is fine a little light
woods are nice
you start going for a week-long trek in
the wood
you are it there's a problem
and some of these joggers that go into
these national parks to get abducted
it's
just [ __ ] jog on the street
but it's a better yeah it looks nice
well then you take your risk
but this whole thing i'm i'm a little
sick of these [ __ ] corporate tech
pieces of [ __ ] pretending that they give
a flying [ __ ] about nature
they don't they don't okay
all these [ __ ] people at burning man
which is
virtual this year god forbid they not
have
burning man it's got to be a zoom
meeting of burning man
so these people that work at goldman
sachs who spend their day
destroying economies and these people
that design
uh you know uh the type of security
systems that uh
keep the children in cages for ice
they need to go do a virtual burning man
this year because it's not like the real
thing
they can't dress up like a [ __ ] weird
starfish
weird steampunk angel on roller skates
and go [ __ ] around in the black rock
desert
so they can recharge themselves to go
sit behind their desk
and take more of your freedom and
control more of your mind
that's what all those new age burning
man types are doing
they're leaving that [ __ ] thing and
then deleting you on social media
they're they're they're they're a
burning man and they're like
and then they go back to their [ __ ]
office and and they just program
fights for you they just program how
many family members you should fight
with for the next
three months they just say ah
everybody's [ __ ] it's all fun when
you're eating you know peyote
[ __ ] you know frittatas or whatever's
going down there
that's my my my my opinion on that stay
the [ __ ]
stop pretending to be some connoisseur
of the natural world you're a demon from
hell
own it own it
what happened to the old wall street
types michael douglas in wall street
wasn't like you know what i
you know what i really like i like
winning
i like winning and yosemite i love
yosemite
because the hot springs no
own it enough with these [ __ ]
benny's returned to the show ben was
suspended for a week he had a suspension
uh because an article came out about him
in the la times where he was accused of
multiple rapes
[Laughter]
and uh he was just and we thought that
the punishment for that was a suspension
for a week
and one of the one of the women is
alleging that he branded her and
uh so he's now back and
if we're sourcing these claims and if it
is true
he will be suspended for another week
and then that will be that will be his
punishment but we're not we haven't
we haven't really found the validity in
them
we're going to start putting up new
dates on instagram tim j dillon
d-i-l-o-o-n
twitter tim j dillon d-i-l-l-o-n
follow me on facebook tim dillon tim
dilloncomedy.com
we are going to throw some new dates up
we're back on the road september october
november
we've got dates we're coming to texas
we're coming to florida we are going
places
as soon as all of those offers and deals
that we have
cooking as long as we can verify that
they're gonna happen and we can put
those tickets on sale
we're going out we've got some new
materials some old materials some
crowd work some riffing some [ __ ]
just having fun talking about this
craziness that we're in
uh subscribe rate review our podcast
five stars
tell friends about it if you like it uh
rate us on itunes tell everybody about
us call spotify tom to give us a [ __ ]
hundred million dollars
uh whatever you wanna do this is uh we
appreciate this the show's grown
dramatically
it's only gonna grow more hopefully and
uh
we're looking at some some new options
for later on in the year early next year
we're gonna have a cool new studio
um you know we're taking a lot of the
production quality the videos has gone
up you've noticed we're going
uh in a different direction hopefully we
have a fully functional
like kind of like a late night show
that's actually funny wouldn't that be
nice an
actual funny late night show eventually
so
like something that you could actually
watch oh that was comedic and i enjoyed
it
which is nothing that is happening right
now
there's not one thing you think is funny
truly there's not what the only funny
thing right now
truly to watch is the news because
literally you watch it and you just see
you know people climbing through the
windows and fridays with
blow torches and you go
honey you got to come in here and see
you got to come in here
big guy he's got a bat he's in i think
he's ruby tuesdays
[Laughter]
i can't wait i can't wait for trump to
not
accept the election results or whatever
when there to be like this weird civil
war but by the way all of this military
stuff is there the military is sending a
strong signal with trump
don't count on us that's what a lot of
it is they're sending a strong signal
going
don't count on us we're not with you um
and i just can't wait for that to happen
and there to be like some real
uh just civil unrest and some real
problems in the country and then uh
you know uh one of these guys on wall
street's you know just drinking a
cabernet
and he's just sitting there and he just
you know like
turns on the tv and he's just scenes
like trying to understand he's like
squinting
he's squinting and he's just seeing you
know burning and everything like that
and he just
he just kind of shuts it off and then he
goes ah you know
his wife goes what's going on is there a
problem he goes you know they blow it up
the media they make it bigger than it is
you know
everything's fine everything's okay and
he just [ __ ] ignores it just [ __ ]
lights a cigar and everything like that
and then
he hears like the sound of distant
chanting and he goes it's probably
it's interesting you know the neighbors
are loud they're usually not that loud
but i guess you're having an event you
know and he smiles he goes it's nice to
have parties he remembers when he used
to have parties
and the chanting's growing louder and he
doesn't understand pretending he's
growing louder and now he's a little
curious he gets up he's got to cigar
maybe maybe he's moved on from the
cabernet maybe a little sniffed or a
brandy or something you know he's a
macallan a nice whiskey and
he just sees and all of a sudden he just
sees the uh
you know he just sees the people and
many of them are in black and many of
them aren't and they're just
they're angry and they're and they're
carrying things that look like weapons
you know batons and clubs and things
like that
and maybe one guy's got a chainsaw and
now he's a little nervous
he's a little nervous he doesn't he
doesn't quite
understand what's uh what's going on you
know and they they come into his
property and they start lighting it on
fire
and now he's he's a little disappointed
you know he's
he doesn't really mind the house burning
down because the house was never what he
wanted he loves the property and he
thinks maybe i mean i'm
sure maybe i could build something else
so even in the initial stages of them
burning his home he sees the opportunity
in it ryan he sees this could be like a
blessing in disguise you know he sees
the thing going up and he goes well you
know i got a good policy on this house
you know and even if the wife gets it he
goes you know me and her haven't been
connecting
we haven't been connecting as much you
know so he sees the opportunity and i i
mean i mean maybe she gets horribly
scarred and
he just sends her away to some
sanitarium and then he could kind of
you know uh you know call that waitress
at bobby vance and said harvard that he
really likes you know and
you know because she's an older woman
but she's you know big tits and she gets
them and
she likes power and she appreciates him
you know not like his wife does anymore
she doesn't appreciate him you know this
new one does because you know
she's new and new is important and new
is good you know and
it's been a while since he's had any
news so he's watching his house burn
down and he's thinking about maybe his
wife being horribly scarred
and still and still there's
nothing that's really troubling him and
then
a couple of the people start to approach
him and he says to himself
yeah it's it's not a huge deal i mean
i'm sure they just want to talk and then
then they kind of start pushing them and
this is when he goes
now his physical safety starts to enter
his mind for the very first time in the
whole equation
and he goes yeah this is you know this
is a real
this is a real issue and uh i don't know
how i'm gonna make it out of this you
know
he's thinking in his mind as you know
any fighting moves not really
not really you know he's been in only a
few scrapes he's lost most of them you
know he's a wiry framed small man that
made all his money
you know just you know closing down the
companies that he imagined big surly
guys
work at you know and so they're they're
they're
they're um they're they're they're now
getting him and now they've hoisted him
up and they're
carrying him and he's now very
uncomfortable because he he now realizes
that this might just go left here you
know like even though he's tried really
really hard this just
this may not this may not be a good
equation this might just end very
very badly and he doesn't he doesn't
really know where this is going to go
and they
they walk him and then they're walking
him to a tree
in the middle of his property it's a big
tree he's always loved this tree you
know
and they they're just you know they they
start tying him around this tree and he
goes this seems very strange you know it
reminds him actually of
one of these kind of fun rituals they
used to do bohemian grove he thought
maybe that was going to be it he's like
maybe they just want to have fun in
nature you know nature huh
but no they start tying him around a
tree and then they start dousing him
with something and he recognizes that
smell it's kerosene
it's kerosene and they're dashing him
and finally he goes oh i think they're
gonna light me on fire he's still very
calm and collected you know
he didn't realize he was gonna die like
this but he's had a pretty decent life
you know he's made a lot of money some
people have made more a hell of a lot of
people have made less you know
the kids went to the best schools he's
only cheated on the wife a few times and
he
tested himself for stds before he had
sex with her again he's done everything
responsibly and right you know
and he just he's there and he's just you
know soaked in kerosene he just
wants he doesn't want to say anything
offensive he doesn't want he's thinking
of legacy now you know you think of his
legacy and
it's kind of a proud legacy to be burned
at the stake in the hamptons really
by an angry mob you know he'll probably
be remembered if he is remembered it'll
probably be with some type of sympathy
right it'll
in there
they're burning them and they're they
haven't burned them yet but they all
have torches and they're
they're getting ready to burn them and
he's just there and he's he's doused in
kerosene
and everything like that and he's he's
tied to the tree
and he finally he finally starts
understanding
you know that there are some problems
in america there are issues
in america there and he never he never
understood that
you know and so then they they start
burning him
and he's he's smelling his own flesh
burn
and the pain is so intense he's gritting
his teeth and his teeth are almost
breaking and the blood
is kind of oozing out of his mouth he's
just clenching his teeth and he can't
even
speak there's so much pain
you know there's so much
pain and he's just as he drifts off
and he's just again cooking tied to a
tree
in his southampton home as he's cooking
the last thing that he thinks
to himself is he goes man maybe we
should have let them get a knee
operation
i guess but then he reminds himself that
hindsight is 20 20.
and he cares he cares more about the
fact that as soon as that house is
burned
and that that tree is burned and then
his body's burned a nice
young family of guys like him will move
in there
so even though he's dead his last
thought is you know what
[ __ ] him you know how expensive it is to
put in a new knee
a hell of a lot more pricey if you
multiply it by the amount of people that
really need it
it's a hell of a lot more pricey than
just building a new house
for another hedge fund guy that can just
move in there and that hedge fund guy
will look out at that burnt tree and
he'll maybe
learn a few lessons but i bet he won't
you know
so even in the last throws of
consciousness he decides against the
knee operations
he says [ __ ] it you know what the
system's important
what is my flesh what is what do i have
to say
that will ever be greater than the
system that's what gets people up in the
morning
right my life is nothing
so he kind of has a smile on his face he
has a smile on his face
and it's charred you can kind of see it
but the smile is because the last
thought he had he goes
man the next guy who buys this property
is gonna get such a good
[ __ ] deal
good night